what do you think is more dangerous
conspiracy-wise the world economic
forums great reset or
cnn putting coveted numbers at the top
of the screen
for emotional manipulation uh i think
that they're both put they're both
pretty dangerous which is
kind of dodging the question but um it
goes back to my point that you know
no one's shared reality is going to be
perfectly absent
off you know nonsense because we all end
up believing nonsense based on you know
what our in group believes and we all
confirm our own biases
the one the uh therefore the ones we
should be most critical of
the the shared realities we should be
most uh
alert to are the ones that come from
universities and the mainstream media
and these big organizations like the
world economic forum because those
institutions have power
whereas you know random anonymous
message board with q posters does not
i think a lot of what we're seeing is
great reset stuff you know
so they're they're it was interesting
someone made the point that when they
announced
15 days to slow the spread mark
zuckerberg said we're not going to
reopen until next june
you know like a year from now or
whatever and then sure enough
that's when a bunch of the states are
lifting their their lockdowns as if
mark zuckerberg knew or it's a
coincidence whatever the point is a lot
of these businesses took action
whether it mattered to the pandemic or
not a lot of
these states were doing things that had
nothing to do with the pandemic for
for instance there was a woman in north
new jersey who was selling things on
facebook online
she had a little resale shop and when
they shut all the businesses down
she was in her business and she was
filming things saying if you see
anything you like just let me know and
we'll ship it out
and the cops showed up with a smile on
their face and said ma'am you can't do
what you're doing
and she was like what do you mean we're
they're like you have to close your
storage because we are closed
no ma'am you can't live stream your
products and then sell them
what does that have to do with covid and
why did these cops go and do it
those cops should be fired but uh
like 25 percent of people who have not
left their homes
throughout all of kobe something insane
like that that that serious delusion
that uh you know people want to talk
about q and stuff like
those people i'm scared of those people
i'm i'm terrified of these people
because
they vote and it's it's like you see
these videos there's one video recently
of a woman wearing it's like she made
out of pvc
pvc pipe this like the square rectangle
thing goes over her body with plastic
sheets
and then like her hands can come out
through gloves
and she's walking around with this thing
you see videos i wonder how many of
these are jokes
right because we bought the space helmet
thing which is really funny i have this
thing it's called like micro climate and
it's like a space helmet
i got i gotta admit though i bought it
as a gag because it was funny
but it's really useful when i'm cleaning
out the garage and there's all the dust
and pollen and
you know i would go in there you know
and i try to clean out the dust a bit
and i'm sneezing like crazy and i'm like
i'm gonna wear my space helmet
and it works it's beautiful it's big and
it's got air filters in it
actually really no advertisements you
didn't know you needed yeah maybe they
should market it as like when you're
cleaning in a dusty place
yes and you need filters because of you
know yeah and for your eyes too
but anyway you have a lot of these
people who who believe the most insane
things these videos where like
people are walking down the street
wearing you know a hazmat suit or
something
and they jump out of the way of people i
have friends
and it's like dude i get it i understand
there's a concern about covid
but some people just go nuts yeah i mean
i understand if you like in a vulnerable
uh vulnerable group if you're older or
if you have some sort of condition that
makes you particularly at risk to due to
covert but like
normal healthy people are doing this
like i got it
it's not just the lockdown it's like the
extremism it's the wearing the weird
hazmat suits with like an air canister
gutted me
of everything i've seen in the last two
years is the baby when the baby was born
in plastic and then the mom like pressed
it against her
all the pressing the baby's face against
the plastic sheet
so it was protected i don't know i don't
know it was just so
sad to be a for the baby's first
experience in life to be smooshed into
plastic um
right right the point i'm trying to get
to is that there are a lot of people who
believe in sane conspiracy theories that
are unfounded
not even the mainstream media is saying
it but there's no criticism from
journalists over what
crazy people are saying you've got to
because you've got to be so careful
because you can get banned for
criticizing
specific things you don't even know what
they are i'm not saying that i'm saying
cnn's brian shelter will never come out
and say antifa is a problem
he's done it like when andy no got
attacked he did a blurb where he's like
a journalist shouldn't get attacked
see i there we go anyway moving on
tucker carlson by the way
they won't do it so yes we all know q
anon is bad
we all know these people believe crazy
things and they never seem to give up
one we don't talk about the the fringe
far left conspiracies
the the lunatics who believe in saying
you know insane things about like
i i the left always tries to disavow
this like what conspiracies well there's
like a whole bunch of weird
medicinal websites that are run by
crystal woo-woo people who are leftists
who are socialists who are hippies on
farms who believe in saying things about
medicine
and about hospitals the media doesn't
talk about that
they they talk about anti-vaxxers but
they only ever highlight
like a conservative or just like some
random person on the internet
they don't talk about russiagate
literally four years of the mainstream
media propping up completely fake news
and and they still do it every single
day so
it's going to be it's going to be
fantastic look this this bill in florida
maybe they won't be able to actually
enforce these things but there's a
provision saying that
news organizations can't be banned based
on their content i haven't
i look i'll prophase by saying i'm not
loyal but like the lawyers i've talked
to say
it's extremely difficult for that to get
past the first amendment unless you also
have some kind of common carrier
or public accommodation requirement i'll
say this about the the florida bill
though it does have a pretty strong
transparency requirement that can't be
dodged uh you know by appeals of the
constitution or to 230. so that could be
interesting it might force these tech
companies to really know
show us what's going on with their
algorithms although they might just do
that and say okay yeah we are sentencing
you we don't care
what do you want at the very least a
bunch of lawsuits will be filed at the
state level
yep yep that will happen and then what's
facebook going to do they have to deal
with
i mean we talked about the other day you
got 21 million people in in florida
let's say a little around half of them
are republicans
around 20 are probably paying attention
on social media because that's the
number on twitter and two percent of
those are active on twitter
actually posting so you can have between
a couple hundred thousand
or you know tens of thousands of people
and millions of people
who might actually have issue with these
social media companies
many of them might file lawsuits and
have grounds to do so
they don't mind but it's doubtful in my
view that any of those will you know
survive in court i think the tech
companies will win
now the state level at the state level
now the uh but how if they
if the state passes the law and then
they go to a court in that state and say
see what your law says that's what they
did the tech companies will just take it
to the federal they would have to appeal
to the feds but that still means they're
going to be
attacked on multiple fronts that they
have to pay for these lawyers
they're gonna have to take it to court
and it's gonna cost them a lot of money
and they're not gonna get their court
costs back
uh not that much not not uh it's
very hard to impose financial
consequences on the tech companies that
they actually care about
and it would have to exceed the
financial cost that the media can impose
on them by whipping up ad boycotts
and that's like hundreds of uh billions
billions well the
the problem ultimately is none of these
things individually it's our community
it is that we don't care about each
other or our country we have no
no shared interests no shared goals
every the country is split not just down
the middle
because sure there's a culture war with
a left and a right whatever that you
know whatever those factions may be
but there's subcategories within these
factions that are fighting with each
other
that dislike each other the states are
another instance of you know factional
conflict
and these boycotts are the most insane
i'm sorry these these corporations and
the ad boycotts are the stupidest things
ever
you know you see coke now backtracking
oh no we didn't mean to criticize
georgia
it's just absolutely insane that these
corporations
are deciding to sacrifice their business
for like seven percent of the country
one way to look at it is that
centralization is fighting
decentralization
like the internet has busted up
everyone's shared realities we're now
going into you know the realities we
like best but
uh the the forces of centralization are
trying to fight that by suppressing all
these
ideologies and imposing one shared
progressive world view on everyone
what needs to happen is the law needs to
follow
uh the trend of decentralization and
actually create
and culture needs to create more
tolerance for you know diverse
viewpoints because
viewpoints are getting more diverse as
you know shared reality breaks down
i see why the centralization is is doing
that because
historically if uh if a culture would
permeate or break apart
it would be taken over by outside forces
so there they want to make sure it's a
strong but if we
if we evolve the decentralized system so
that it communicates properly with
itself then we should still have similar
security to a centralized system
maybe they maybe they really do like
that it's breaking down maybe it's just
uh i mean look the great reset this uh
it's funny when i see people on twitter
say it's a conspiracy theory and i'm
like but here's their website it's the
world economic forum it's the davos
group it's
a bunch of extremely wealthy and
powerful individuals around the world
saying they're doing this and they're
going to do it and here's what they're
going to do and they're all woke
yeah the conspiracy isn't that it exists
the conspiracy is
the actual thing they're doing it's it's
it's not a theory it's a conspiracy fact
small group of people
decided to make make some moves and make
some stuff happen
i guess conspiracy implies crime so
they're not literally advocating for
crimes they're saying everybody should
have a stake in the globe and
look what's happening the price of wood
and
steel have skyrocketed bacon coffee
chicken everything's
inflating like crazy the gold to lumber
ratio is nearing one it's at 1.1 or
something what does it mean exactly
so i i don't know exactly but it's it's
it's it's it's
been this way before it's supposed to be
a good sign
that there's going to be some kind of
normalization but it does show that
lumber is skyrocketing up to gold gold
isn't going down so it's inflationary
which means your savings will become
worthless
your salaries will need to go up
substantially but what's gonna happen is
there's gonna be a period where people
can't buy things
you're not gonna be able to build a new
house you're not going to be able to
expand your company and buy and
have new projects there's going to be a
very serious recession maybe even a
depression
and that means your savings will be
worthless
people people need to understand this
man they don't they don't understand how
dangerous it is one of the reasons doge
and ethereum and bitcoin are probably
skyrocketing because
not that look i'm sure the meme has a
lot to do with it
dogecoin haha it's so funny he was at 63
cents or something 67
at one point but it's a lot of people
saying
i don't want to have us dollars right
now so what can i do with it
oh here's a meme people have confidence
in this thing
i'll buy some of that but bitcoin and
ethereum have real value ethereum as a
function as an actual
uh tool function for a lot of different
services and bitcoin just as
a digital store of value and first in
best dressed
so people are trying to find a way to
not hold us dollars i certainly
that's certainly my perspective which is
why gold and silver are you know also on
my mind as well
i think people need to understand if you
work right now for one hour
and that one hour of labor gives you
enough currency to buy
you know maybe a meal at a restaurant if
you hold on to that
in four months that will not be able to
buy you anything anymore
that money that you had that one point
could have bought you that chicken
dinner
won't be able to buy you even a soda
that's what inflation means
it means the labor you do is constantly
being devalued as time goes on
so you need to put your money somewhere
where the value is retained stored or
will increase
and inflation by definition means that
it's getting bigger faster
so the the less valuable it gets the
faster it gets less
valuable that's otherwise it would be a
linear deflation
it is in it is if that's such a thing a
linear deflation people think it can't
happen here
oh it can happen people think it can't
happen in 1928 1929
people lost everything they put all they
they borrowed
bought stock on loans and then when the
stocks tanked they lost they had to pay
back loans
with money they didn't margin calls so
they called in the loans
but they were encouraged to do it by the
financial industry of course of course
of course
you so you take a look at uh weimar
germany and the photos of people
shoveling
you know worthless marks in the street
you look at venezuela
it could happen here and people think it
can't and i'm like no it can
maybe maybe uh we don't know when or why
but it's really amazing how we've had
such a long period of sustained
prosperity that people just can't fathom
hardship i think they're going to do a
currency recall where they say give us
your dollars and for every dollar you
give us we're going to give you a token
of this new currency and you have two
years after two years your dollars are
worth zero
and that's a hard stop the funny thing
is they can just say that right
if like you know biden came out right
now and said the u.s dollar is no longer
going to be backed by the us government
then people would be like uh 200 dollars
people hiding
cash in their under their mattress
that's the stupidest thing too you saw
that story about the grandfather who
who hid 50 grand in their floorboards 50
grand
you know 67 years ago was hundreds of
thousands of dollars in buying power
should have stored some gold in that box
should have stored some dogs
70 years ago buy some doge and put it
and put it cold 70s some cold storage
in like 20 years so some people have
been saying that dogecoin is going to be
cash
because it can be it can it never stops
getting printed right there's no oh yeah
that
works much better as a currency than
bitcoin does
right right so so bitcoin uh it's funny
because people are saying the current
state of bitcoin defies the
the original intent of bitcoin it's a
deflationary currency though
there's there's entropy this coins will
slowly just be lost and destroyed
and eventually they can't be produced
anymore so the value can only go up
doge can be printed and is made forever
so a lot of people are like that's why
doge is better as a currency because the
money market can expand with the economy
would it not be the greatest thing ever
if one doge became one dollar and
and it stayed there forever the buying
power of a dollar right now
and it just normalized and then in 50
years
people are like you know pulling up
their phone like how much for the uh the
whopper meal
at 43 doge okay and they scan their
phones and it's not even a joke anymore
it's just literally just doge like yo
toss me 50 doge man i want to go pick up
some pizzas
and you're like alright dude and you
swipe your phone you're like hook it up
they're like cool cool
how many shibuyas do you think got
bought in 2021 so far
is that the type of dog that it is yeah
that's the type of yeah how many i think
were adopted over
i bet it just created 12 months yeah
power to the shibuya
right it would it would be funny if doge
becomes the i don't think
i think it will i think it's good that
bitcoin has a finite supply so that you
can't over inflate it like some crazy
guy can't be like i'm going to print 100
trillion and keep 990 billion of them
um but that will just keep making new
currencies that have finite supplies
and you know ahead of time what we're
getting into and that's how we'll be
able to have an infinite supply
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you